ah qu'est-ce qu'on leur offre
[Musique]
d'accueillir notre invité chez norbert
tarayre c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
c'est un de mes rêves de vous avoir
autour de la table moi c'est mon rêve de
venir à chaque fois ici c'est vrai qu'un
jour on pourra travailler ensemble
j'espère franchement ça serait ce serait
une très bonne nouvelle pour moi
attention et n'aura contre norbert c'est
parti la plus petite carte
je tire le premier récit allez y goûtera
pas mal madoff c'est pas mal aussi mais
je vais tout dégâts sont énormes
bouda
[Musique]
qui est sous le panda qui est trans là
je commence à avoir une idée a les héros
fait paris s'il tonne
boucher débouchage sera coiffé décoiffé
j'adore c'est bien si beau gosse bassine
avec un cadeau adéquat bah j'ai fait un
petit truc pour vous enfin pour l'équipe
j'ai revisité le père c'est quoi de
pièces à la con il n'y a pas de quoi
manger aujourd'hui pourquoi mais coûte 5
fois c'est un ceviche quoi c'était quoi
ben pour revisiter tu as trouvé le truc
le filet on s'en fout de fait le poison
les écailles on s'en fout les jeunes
[Applaudissements]
alors norbert et gens vous allez être
opposé pour un happening cuisine
isabelle morini bosc et gilles verdez à
attacher donc un pied valhalla les l'un
avec l'autre
vous avez donc deux bras donc un bras
chacun et vous allez devoir faire une
omelette
alors prenez d'abord les ingrédients de
la famille woerth c'est comme ça les 6
restant
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes un deux trois
[Musique]
on va appeler le goûteur de l'émission
géant louvain qui était spécialisée non
alors gérard alémanique c'est la
magnifique parfaitement à sa folie qui
n'aimait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]